[Music]
what do Game of Thrones and gladiator
have in common
both were filmed in this Moroccan desert
[Applause]
[Music]
it's no secret some of our favorite
films and TV shows aren't exactly filmed
on the location we'd expect but Alice
Studios in Morocco might have some of
the most diverse variety of locations
within its studio walls in just steps
you can go from feeling like you're in
ancient Egypt to a medieval castle to a
Buddhist temple the area has always been
a popular choice for Hollywood
starting with Lawrence of Arabia in 1962
since then it's been used for films such
as the live-action Aladdin The Mummy and
gladiator and TV shows such as Game of
Thrones Atlantis and Prison Break the
studio is one of the largest in the
world at over 300 thousand square feet
and its popularity stems from it's
reliable climate that can mimic a
variety of countries tourists are
welcome to visit the site but it will be
an adventure of your own making as Alice
studio is still used as an active film
set however you can schedule a guided
tour to hear all about the set secrets